-Finally, we have
exactly 12 shows left
before we go on Christmas break.
Yeah, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters"!
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 12 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an out-of-this-world
Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are 12 shows left,
let's open door number 12.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Hello.
-Hello.
-Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you, too.
-Oh!
♪♪
It's a sweater.
Oh, my goodness.
This is like a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Got mittens.
It's got mittens there.
This is gorgeous.
It's a Christmas sweater.
Now let's see who's going
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants a sweater?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is 211!
♪♪
Come on over, bud. Hey.
How you doing, bud?
Nice to see you.
Why don't you head over there.
Yeah, go over there.
Nice to see you.
How are you? What is your name?
-Mike.
-Mike, where are you from?
-New York.
-Mike from New York. I love it.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like your sweatshirt.
Is that just a politeness
or is that a weed reference?
-A little bit of --
A little bit of both.
-A little bit of both. Yeah.
Mike, in New York,
it gets a little cold.
Do you have anything
like this at home?
-I actually have
an elf onesie, so--
-Oh, this is
going to go perfect.
You can lend that out
to someone else
and go to the party
wearing this one.
Would you like to try it on?
-I guess so.
-Yeah, go for it. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, that's very nice.
Alright, Mike,
this is going to be good.
Mike, I feel like
this is going to work.
-Yeah? You think so?
-Yeah.
I feel like this is your thing.
Yeah, yeah.
They're for--
You're forced to wear mittens
while wearing
this sweater, yeah.
Oh, this is perfect.
The thumbs reverse
on that one, so, yeah,
you have to get your hand --
Oh, this is -- Mike...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Oh, my God.
There he goes right there,
Mike from New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look fantastic, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Let's give Mike
another round of applause.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Adam Sandler, everybody.
Come on back.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]